this is expected to be the busiest
weekend of Memorial Day travel since
before the pandemic AAA in fact saying
more than 42 million people are expected
to travel 50 miles or more from their
home that is an increase of nearly 3
million people from last year Chris Van
Cleave is at Chicago's O'Hare Airport
one of the nation's busiest even on a
not so busy day Chris how's it looking
well good morning Tony it is looking
very busy in fact we've already seen the
TSA checkpoints surge between Saturday
and Wednesday they screened more than 12
million Flyers that's about 700 000 more
than pre-pandemic O'Hare is expecting
about a million and a half people to
pass through these Halls this weekend
alone
sites of a summer travel season taking
off
jammed freeways and packed airports that
could be even busier today I'm excited
that
good to travel again after
Richmond got to the Atlanta airport more
than three hours before her flight
taking no Chances with her big Memorial
Day European Cruise even adding three
extra days on the front and end of the
trip in case of any travel disruptions
delays mix up with flights anything with
the cruise luckily my travel insurance
will help me cover that the nation's
Airlines have been working for a year to
get ahead of last Summer's staffing
issues that snarled flights for Millions
I think it's improved compared to a year
ago but the real test of that will be
going into the summer Transportation
secretary Pete budage is planning new
regulations requiring Airlines to
compensate flyers for some lengthy
delays but is facing criticism for
continuing Air Traffic Control problems
last summer you were very hard on the
airlines about their staffing issues a
year later ATC is still having its own
staffing issues why hasn't that gotten
fixed well look we're going to own
anything that's under our control we're
talking about five percent of the issue
and as long as that's more than zero
then we're going to continue growing the
air traffic control Workforce the data
is wrong United Airlines CEO Scott Kirby
the reality is that air traffic control
delays which includes weather by the way
are overwhelmingly the initiator of
delays that then Cascade through the
system Air Traffic Control challenges
are really the number one concern for me
as we head into the summer and as we
look to the Future the airlines can stop
up over the course of a year and can
hire pilots and can hire flight
attendants
it's different for air traffic
controllers you know that fast we have
and we did but there's still shortages
well look we're always growing the
workforce and covid blew a hole in our
training pipeline but we've been able to
add a lot of controllers 1500 coming
online Tim lawland is just trying to
take whatever the Summer Rush brings in
stride excited for some of it we've read
some of it yeah Airport's never fun but
the destination destination is
now the TSA expects today will be its
busiest day at checkpoints Nationwide
AAA is forecasting that the busiest time
if you are driving it's between 3 and 6
p.m in most major cities that's today so
think about watching CBS mornings and
then getting on the road or waiting
until Saturday morning and this holiday
weekend by the way airports expect to
stay busy through Wednesday as what once
was a three-day weekend is becoming a
six day summer starter Nate
I know all about this too well flew in
last night at eight waited till 11 to
get my bags too many flights and not
enough gates open Chris thank you